brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system hey
folks Chris waters here on the front
lines at South by Southwest with a man
who though he himself is a not a
minister and has been not been to hell
nevertheless has been making a game for
over four years about that very subject
Thomas the game is pinstripe yep so the
game is called pinstripe and it's a game
about an ex-minister who goes to hell to
look ex-minister he's not a minister
anymore and he goes to hell and he's
looking for his little daughter bow-wow
all right that's all you're really
setting us up already for something
that's quite emotional I mean the stakes
are kind of high yeah so the game is
it's it's the goal is to have this
strong emotional strand through the
entire game but it's also focused on a
ton of atmosphere so the music the
development in the design and the
illustration all done by me over four
years going on five years and those all
sort of fit together in one cohesive
whole so what inspired the art style
because it sort of I almost got this
storybook feel to it what were you going
so I'm going for basically I mean like a
ton inspiration from Tim Burton that's
all I can really think about the top of
my head not a bad source of inspiration
I mean I loved his work growing up and
I'm ashamed to say it from a story
perspective I love M night Shyamalan
movies I love his movies and I will
stand firm on that and that his stories
are sort of inspirational to my story
for the game alright so some twists and
turns to be expected and pinstripe it
seems but I did yeah it was already
taken you gotta do it di do different
one alright so but let's talk about the
the gameplay sort of as the players
exploring what kind of is it is it
action based as a puzzle based slip mix
of the two yeah so the whole goal all
along for the entire game has been to
make a really simple game from a
gameplay perspective like the mechanics
so those those are just like basic
platforming and talking to people and
doing simple fetch quests
I want people to feel like a kid again
and so when I was a kid I just wanted to
go run through the woods and pretend and
make believe so that's the goal with the
game nothing too complicated very cool
elegant in its simplicity yes absolutely
all right well pinstripe I been working
for quite some time on it is the end in
sight what you think if you have a
release window or some platforms you're
targeting yeah so thankfully yesterday a
history i've got kick-started over three
hundred percent of its funding goal so
thank you kickstarter thank you for that
because of that i can work full time on
it I quit my job two weeks ago and I can
work full time on this game and finally
get this stupid thing done its bit it's
been so long and I'm planning on
releasing in August on Steam and then
October september-october is going to be
mobile well Thomas best of luck to you
man with pinstripe very exciting time
for you and for folks who are fan of
hell journeys hmm
you